saradici is a YouTuber and entrepreneur
with over 870 000 subscribers in
extremely interesting story and a rather
unorthodox rise to success in this
episode we discuss how she makes 800k
with her unique YouTube strategy and
talk about her startup that has raised
over a quarter million dollars and is
launching in the next couple of months
and here's a hint there's a lot more
than meets the eye I'm going through
some drama with him right now so if this
is something you're interested in and
you want to see more like it make sure
to subscribe because we post new
episodes every single Sunday and they
all have to do with making money
personal finance building up a business
and just becoming wealthier uh did I
miss anything Jack I think that's great
all right enjoy but before we get into
that we want to thank today's sponsor
MooMoo Mumu is an advanced One-Stop
trading app that not only allows
investors to do everything they need but
it also provides a community to exchange
ideas MooMoo helps you monitor Market
movements perform deep technical
analysis quickly screen for stocks and
provides a community where Traders can
exchange ideas they also give you access
to global asset sets meaning you'll be
able to trade in Hong Kong and U.S
stocks all from the same fantastic app
and that's just another really great
feature that sets MooMoo apart from
everybody else and best of all when you
deposit just 100 MooMoo will give you
six free stocks and each stock is worth
between eight and twenty five hundred
dollars that's literally free money and
MooMoo doesn't just allow you to buy and
sell stocks they also give you access to
so many other really cool features that
allow you to take your trading game to a
whole new level like their real-time
level 2 Trading data for the U.S stock
market which displays up to 60 levels of
bids and asks which also gives you
real-time quotes and helps you gain a
deeper understanding of the market so
get up to 10 free stocks with MooMoo
today using that link Down Below in the
description again guys the link is down
below in the description to get up to 10
free stocks with Mumu it also really
helps support the podcast thank you so
much MooMoo and back to the podcast
unpart them
are you serious
this is is not the first glass oh my
gosh out of control what's up my name is
Sarah D she rhymes with peachy this is
the iced coffee hour and you guys have
made 251
000 plus
257. oh I mean a thousand dollars is
that the closest I think that might is
that the closest I think so that's
either the closest or the second closest
it's really not that hard all you really
have to do is watch the last episode
yes yes yes well welcome thank you so
much for coming here you are a College
Dropout Tech YouTuber making money
making products yeah yeah LED with
College Dropout because it's very timely
with the news today but um so I've been
thinking about it but haven't thought
about it in a while oh that's a good
question did you because you went to
college for a little bit did you have
any debt no so that's actually what led
to the dropping out because I had a
scholarship okay so I had an electrical
engineering scholarship I went to UTA if
there's any uh Texans out there there
and I did that for about two and a half
years but it's very hard to maintain a
3.5 GPA when you're studying doubly and
so I lost it I also hated electrical
engineering so I was like I want to try
something new I went to Belmont randomly
because I like Nashville changed my
major to computer computer science
didn't have a scholarship anymore one
semester was fifteen thousand dollars
it and I had to like pay that out of
pocket so I had no money after one
semester and I was like this is stupid
I'm not learning anything video thing
was working out and then I dropped out
so yeah no debt would it have changed
knowing that ten thousand dollars would
have been forgiven that would be another
semester
over the edge dude I'm going to continue
a little bit longer and I will say I
feel like I was one of those people who
once this started to be a conversation
about debt relief there was a little
part of me of like man I like altered my
entire life because I didn't want to go
into debt so it doesn't seem fair but at
the same time I'm like I wouldn't be
where I was today without that and I'm
like I feel like everyone would be
better off without the crippling debt so
now I'm like
it'd be great if in a perfect world it
didn't affect other things you know
um but you know inflation is a Hot Topic
right now so who knows what that would
do but I just hate
everything
to do with college I graduated top 10 I
got good grades I knew I had a little
money in college but I knew it wasn't
going to pay for four years so I was
like I need Jewel in high school so I
can get a scholarship and so I was
always like ticking those boxes and you
know go home to Christmas and be like
hey Grandma and Grandpa electrical
engineering degree doing good
um so I did feel that pressure but it
got to a point where it was so
overwhelming I loved making videos it
was just a matter of time how can I make
this my job so it took me like three
years of doing it on the side to figure
it out and then I dropped out with only
4 000 YouTube subscribers how much were
you making at the time from YouTube it
wasn't a thing so I I had clients with a
agency in Nashville so I basically
linked up with a local photographer who
I did like a docu-series on
um that got like a thousand views you
know
he had some already existing clients at
like a creative agency he had no idea
how to do video but he was kind of like
hey this girl knows what she's doing so
if I take my high paying clients and say
hey we do video now
um looking back
it was a terrible deal for me I would do
all of the work and he'd pay me like 500
bucks or a thousand bucks and I would be
like shooting editing doing everything
and he would just be on set being like
looks good but it paid my rent you know
my rent in Nashville is like 600 bucks
so you're doing contract work at the
time just to get this yes yes and it was
one of those things where I was posting
YouTube every single week I was obsessed
with it I was like I have to make this
my job and I was doing so many things I
was going to like all the conferences
and there was a conference called Adobe
Max in LA and I had a friend's cousin
who we had gone to LA and visited and so
it was like a free place to stay and so
I was like okay they had College pricing
for the conference and I was like that's
300 bucks so I can figure that out
um and I have a free place to stay and I
went there made a lot of cool
connections I met someone at Adobe
learned about this thing called the
Adobe Creative residency so basically in
a span of like six months I dropped out
of college I was doing like the side
work was going ham on YouTube only 4 000
subscribers
um but then I kind of long story short
connected some dots got this thing
called the Adobe Creative residency
where they pay you for a year to just be
creative and share the process along the
way and literally when I was in the
interviews the final interviews for that
I made my viral video about Casey
neistat and so all of a sudden I had
like a essentially a contract for a year
that just paid me a salary and I went
from 4 000 subscribers to 100 000
subscribers in the span of two days and
I was like okay it's go time and yeah
the rest is history so it's 2016. what
was the Casey neistat video yes so it
was like a parody on his Vlog so he had
just hit I think a million subscribers
it was in I guess somewhat the beginning
days and I was obsessed with his videos
like everyone else and I uh I was just
in Nashville and I was making videos
every week so I was like to you know
this this week's video I'm gonna make a
parody and it went super viral so it's
like a four minute video of me talking
you know being quirky like Casey does I
don't know how to describe it
um it's very cringe watching it back now
it is so cringe
um but yeah he shouted it out in his
video the next day and I was literally I
was sitting at in Nashville on a on a
job and I think it was like interviews
for this thing called the Bible bee have
you heard of that no it's where it's
where people get together and answer
questions about the Bible and it's like
a game show and so I had I got this job
where I was doing interviews with
everyone from the Bible V and I was
sitting there and like my phone was
blowing I was going on
um and all I saw was a comment from
Casey and he said OMG when the video had
like 500 views and I was like
huh
and so I just like I was like shaking
you know during the interview
um and yeah the next day you posted the
video and then I posted another video
that was like zero to forty thousand
subscribers in one day and then that
second video blew up
and then I started daily vlogging that
was a mess and then I came back around
to check yeah so was your growth because
Casey neistat shouted it out or because
the algorithm was pushing the video so
definitely Casey shouted me out I was
like one of his first big shout outs so
there and it was like Peak Casey where
of course he didn't have as many
subscribers as he does now but the you
know million people that were watching
him were obsessed for people who found
Casey in 2015 2016 you're just obsessed
right so if he tells you to go watch
someone it was it was instant it was
crazy but I will say
and I guess maybe this is the one
practical thing people can get from this
I had been posting videos since 2011 and
I had just come off like a second season
of creative spaces TVs like my
docu-series on Creative people and
um we I had a whole series of that to
post right after he shouted me out so I
like had that I had all these tech
reviews
um so I had a huge back catalog of
content with like a thousand views for
people to watch
um so I think that helped people saw my
channel they're like oh she actually
makes good stuff they stayed sure and
yeah how much did you make from that so
the Casey video yeah
I actually have no idea should I check
yeah I I didn't even
AdSense is definitely not my main driver
um let's see is there like data from
2016 I can't find it oh gosh so you
click uh so estimated revenue and then
you go
your fingers already hover right oh
sorry clicked the wrong one okay so
lifetime so you made and I am cool just
to screenshot this one okay oh I thought
it was gonna be way more so it made
1793.64 off of how many views Graham
yeah let me let me tell you 2.1 2.1
million yeah 2.1 million one million
that is crazy to be fair I don't think I
had monetization turned on in the
beginning
there you go because I was I was of this
belief that I just want people to watch
my videos and I don't want something
distracting them from watching my video
so I actually I didn't turn on
monetization until I think a little bit
later
um but I obviously turn it on later but
yeah okay yeah yeah wow that's pretty
cool damn how did you keep that audience
though
yes okay
it was hard because I had you know 100K
people come show up and I wasn't making
parodies I think a lot of people were
like oh okay you should start doing this
with everyone you should make a parody
of every single YouTuber but I'm like
that is not me and so I started vlogging
because everyone was daily vlogging it
almost killed me but so I would like
daily Vlog I had a new season of
creative spaces TV I was working on and
in 2016 uh kind of like filmmaking
YouTube wasn't a thing yet but later on
I was kind of like camera gear and all
this stuff you know became really hot so
I was eventually able to kind of ride
that wave in 2017 but 2016
was a lot of like ups and downs
um I was going everywhere with Adobe I
was going to these conferences I was
meeting a ton of people interviewing
people but in terms of views it like
wasn't that much of a priority
um as crazy as that sounds it was more
like okay how can I do this Adobe
Creative residency and make cool stuff
along the way so
um it would be weird I would post a vlog
that would get like 15K views and then I
would post
like something kind of techy and those
occasionally popped off if I you know
would talk about I got a new Macbook or
something like that and that's what
later informed me okay go back to Tech
because I was posting videos in 2011
2012 just unboxing things and that's
when I kind of was like daily vlogging
is killing you
stop daily vlogging and just make good
stuff so so yeah it was it was it was
hard 2017-2018 is where I kind of got
more of my footing got it yeah but first
we got to thank our sponsor ftxus
because they're giving you a chance to
get all the way up to a hundred dollars
for free crypto when you use the link
Down Below in the description for those
unaware Jack ftxus is one of the largest
US regulated cryptocurrency exchanges in
the world with millions of users who buy
sell track and trade both crypto and
nfts all in one place with fees that are
up to 85 lower than the top competitors
plus buying and selling crypto is
extremely easy all you got to do Jack is
pick what you want to buy type in how
much of it you want to buy how often you
want to buy it and then swipe right and
you're done without any additional work
on your end and you can get free crypto
on every trade you make over ten dollars
another thing that they offer Graham is
recurring Buys so you guys can invest
just like we do and dollar cost average
into the market over time so you don't
have to do it all at once hey Graham can
you go get me a coffee please yeah sure
thanks okay guys while Graham's getting
me a coffee I decided it's a great
opportunity to to tell you they're soon
launching FTX stocks so you'll be able
to trade stocks crypto and nfts all in
one place it's gonna be amazing
definitely check it out with that link
down below so start trading crypto and
nfts with low fees today and again all
you need to do is click the link Down
Below in the description and now let's
get back to the podcast what tech did
you find did the best it was okay what's
crazy is I feel like only recently I
have a pulse on it I don't have the most
like stable YouTube career
um it has it's been just like super
random I feel like but Apple stuff you
know did really well
um luckily it's easy to talk about Apple
stuff because I dig it but I would say
the MacBook was a big driver of my
channel in 2016 they did a huge redesign
of the butterfly keyboard the touch bar
I don't know if you guys like have one
of those MacBooks but it was terrible
and so I had just built like my entire
time
when the new laptop came in me too see
this is Sarah I just want to chime in
here yes I'm a techie you're a techie
they're talking about the touch bar but
they don't know about the tragedy that
is the keyboard yes um and and that's
what really that's what really
progresses
yes Jack so remember when I was planning
out my videos and the keys would fall
off
the floor
because of the touch bar okay well no
okay so they completely redesigned the
keyboard to this butterfly keyboard so
in order to make the uh laptop super
super thin they completely redesigned it
and it was the worst keyboard that has
ever been on a laptop ever and that was
just like the beginning of the those
issues on the computer so all of a
sudden I found myself being like I've
been a Mac User my entire life this is
the worst laptop I've ever used so that
is kind of what started my trajectory
back into Tech because I was racking in
like really good views just trashing on
the MacBook Pro so that is so fun yeah I
just remember there's countless times
I've sat next to Graham while he's
typing on his keyboard and his fingers
would be a little stickier
and then flick off and it'd shoot across
we have to find it yeah sometimes it
would just keep sticking to his fingers
down and put him back down and like oh
my God I still use it from time to time
yeah yeah so the new the new MacBooks uh
they started making uh changes in 2019
and then the big redesign uh came last
year and they're amazing now they
brought back the ports yeah the ports
were fantastic so I have all three so
that was the one where the keys fell off
yeah then I got the one with the touch
bar I'm
and then I got the newest one as of like
uh six months ago I like how has the SD
reader that's yeah me too it's so cool
to be able to plug it in and it's so
exactly fast yeah so the charging is
fantastic I love the charger
plug it in and it's like a 50 within 20
minutes yes
arrived it's good
it's good um
a minute to get to that answer but I
would definitely say the MacBook me
complaining about how terrible the
MacBook Pro was was kind of like okay
Tech works I'm gonna steer a little bit
away from my life because I started to
get in the Vlog thing where I was like
let's do something cool for the day so I
have like entertainment for the Vlog but
this was pre David dobrik and all that
stuff so it wasn't doing crazy things
and buying people cars you know you're
just trying to make an exciting story
out of your day so
um but it still got to me
um so yeah there there were a lot of
like sleepless nights 2016 2017. so I'm
glad I found something a little bit more
sustainable give us some more Tech that
you dislike oh oh goodness how long do
we have a lot okay so I'm gonna go the
other way first because I just made a
video that was saying I'm going to pause
reviews because we've actually arrived
in a place where Tech has gotten pretty
good the MacBook they fixed all the
things because you know us YouTubers
over here just screaming like hey this
is a terrible laptops like Windows PCS I
mean they've got so good that it's one
of those things that people make up
drama for things with the new M2 MacBook
Air it's a great redesign of the MacBook
Air but something that happened is the
256 gig version of the M2 MacBook Air
the SSD is slower and they they didn't
disclose that on the website so the big
drama with that computer is basically oh
my gosh like the speeds are a third of
if you just bought the 512 version so
that's an example of an actual real
problem but
basically people Tech YouTubers will
take that and make like 10 videos about
that and so I was just feeling so
fatigued
yeah he loves it we're down a percent
today yeah
but I will say with financial markets
and things every day you really do have
I seem a little bit new in the news at
least you can talk about them there
might be something
like a video yeah yeah 10 minutes we'll
discuss yeah with tech you know you have
one product that comes out and then it's
just you know it starts a cycle for
months and months so I can imagine the
titles if I did
[Music]
yeah
okay you know what you would do girl
yeah the MacBook is over again okay so
it's funny Apple it's funny that you say
that because I'm I'm trying to do a big
pivot again away from reviews and more
okay let's take if something is topical
let's take it and extrapolate it out to
something like a bigger theme or
something like you know video essays are
really big right now so I did kind of
that Vibe of a video and the title was
this is the end of an era for Apple
which is kind of the vibe of what you
just said that's great um and that's the
end of the era that's bad though so
we're and we're ending about it
and so that was interesting for me
because it was all of a sudden a video
that I enjoyed making
and it wasn't linked to something that
had just come out because the tech world
is crazy something will come out and
you're like fighting everyone who can
get out their video first and that's
complicated even more with an embargo
schedule so certain Tech creators will
get certain Tech before everyone else
does and then they can release their
videos at a certain time and it becomes
a rat race and it's really exhausting
and I became kind of a I just felt like
I was working for all of these companies
without getting paid if that makes sense
hey we'll send you this hey we'll send
you that okay and then what what day do
I have to release it and you know
they're not even paying you but it's
because you have the privilege of
getting hands on with this Tech before
anyone else you feel obligated to make
things now I'm like okay I'll do that
for maybe two or three companies but I
gotta
stop accepting everything because then
you're thinking about what the companies
are thinking you're not thinking about
what makes a good video what makes a
good title thumbnail and so now I'm
actually kind of taking a step back and
being like okay what would actually be a
good title thumbnail and
it's working let's say they send you
something yeah and you say something
negative are they gonna are they gonna
come back and say hey nope let's not
give her anything anymore it's a fine
line okay it's a fine line and that's
and that is why
so oh man
why am I talking about okay so Tech
YouTube is interesting because because
of that what you're bringing up every
other year there's a new phase of
YouTubers Who come out of the Woodworks
and just start like slamming Tech
YouTubers being like this person isn't
honest because they do embargo videos
and they'll just [ __ ] on people for
forever but then they just disappear
because that's not good for growing you
know a following that sticks around
um but it's it's a balance so people
know now and people have gotten way more
honest about it too Tech YouTubers
included so it's just a conversation you
have with your audience like I you know
I tell people there's a very clear line
between of something sponsored if
something's embargoed if someone sent
something to me and that's also the
reason why I'm just it's either
sponsored or it's a Apple iPhone or it's
something that's so crazy that I can't
get my hands on I can't get my hands on
it without the company's help if that
makes sense so I I've there are more you
know distinct lines drawn and you have
to do that as a Creator some of it I've
seen that they can't keep what they're
saying like I mean it's so new right
they have to give it back yes and a lot
of the tech is loans so it's not like
your
you know of course you're gonna be
somewhat cognizant of the fact that you
know a company sent you this you're not
going to completely [ __ ] on it
um but at the same time we're not
keeping this Tech so so what could be
improved with the tech today
oh goodness let's start with the iPhone
what are the problems with the iPhone
the problems with the iPhone files I
hate files oh yeah downloading anytime
you download something yeah it
disappears yeah I could never find that
thing it's gone yeah I will say some of
the so I feel like the hardware is fine
I could totally see them coming out with
a better telephoto camera
um I could see them making a lot uh
watch I just combine two words the notch
uh less noticeable it's rumored that
they're gonna do the punch hole thing so
they're gonna get rid of the notch um so
it'll just be instead of that Notch
it'll be a punch hole camera but we'll
see it's right around the corner and so
I feel like the hardware is good since I
use the iPad a lot
some of the new iPad OS updates have me
a little worried because they're trying
to have this balance between is your
iPad a computer or is it an iPad you
know so they just released a feature
where you have actual window management
now where um you know you don't just
have split view with apps but you can
kind of open up four apps at one time
and switch in between them it's called
stage manager and that's them trying to
make the iPad a computer but it's just
using it in the beta it's not there yet
so
for me I think the only interesting
thing is like the iPad and the software
and where that's gonna go
um but again to my other point I'm kind
of just like I'm good and that's why as
like a tech YouTuber I'm trying to find
more interesting stories to tell because
I don't know I feel like I'm good can I
can I share my interesting qualms about
the iPhone and I think you you will
relate to me uh before I do that I just
want to mention uh Lexar official card
sponsor the podcast
the podcast of you Alex okay so your
officials they're my official sponsor
and uh I record the podcast so anyway
[Laughter]
um I think so for those of you that
don't know um I was an apple Certified
Technician many many years ago and my
biggest qualm with apple
um is repairability and right to repair
um and I think that a lot of people
don't realize this but like you're
charge port you're back when there used
to be a headphone jack whatever they all
used to be replaceable and they still
are replaceable
um but Apple will refuse to provide
those parts and so let's say you break
your charger even though it's on a
separate board which is a very common
problem they'll just like you and I'm
sure a lot of people have experienced it
you go into apple and they're like we
can't fix it you need to we'll buy your
phone for this much and you need to
upgrade or they'll give you a
refurbished product and then that
creates you know a mountain of junk in
another country
um what do you think about that
okay so that has been the biggest
talking point the past couple years so
there's a great YouTube channel by a guy
of the name Lewis Rossman who covers a
lot of this and it has become such a
talking point that Apple has actually
done things to address it granted maybe
not in the most perfect way but recently
they basically announced a self-repair
program where they will literally send
you all of the gear that it takes to
replace a battery or to replace certain
aspects of your phone it's not
everything so they'll send you the
manual they'll send you the official
gear that it takes to do do the
self-repair yourself
um for you know a certain low fee so
they are doing things to remedy that um
so it is cool to see that they are
starting that
um because yeah you're you're right it's
it can be an issue and they lock down
you know computers to to make them
harder to repair
um but but yeah they are taking steps so
hopefully they can continue with that
what do you think of Apple coming out
with a car
it concerns me how it's just a like a it
seems like they're just rotating
Engineers out of there I feel like a lot
of important people have been a part of
the project and then they just leave so
I don't I I it's one of those things
that Apple doesn't do things unless they
can do them right so I can see them
working on it for the next 10 years and
not releasing it until 10 years it's the
same thing with the VR headset I feel
like they do not want to release their
headset until it's perfect until it's
more lightweight than the Oculus until
people can actually have it on for hours
at a time and not get a headache until
they can get the resolution right so
it's one of those things where it's like
I would love to see an Apple car but we
might be waiting like another five to
ten years you know or who knows if it'll
it come out you know if they can't do it
right they're not going to release it
is that uh I love the the theater mode
where it feels like you're in a movie
theater but there's still something odd
about the screen where it's like you see
the pixels it doesn't quite look yeah
it's like a TV exactly yeah and yeah and
that's something that's you know I got
the opportunity to interview the Zuck
which was fun and you know that's
something that he said is it's like all
about iterations like resolution will
get better the headsets will get
lightweight
um they have you know a lot of different
uh you know prototypes with all those
things but it's just like the tech isn't
quite there yet
um but I will say I was so
I judge the Oculus hard I was like this
is so stupid I'm never like who is gonna
do this but when I gave it another shot
with a quest too I became obsessed for
like a week and then I set it down and
never used it again but I can totally
see I'm like this is crazy like this is
crazy playing Putt-Putt with your
friends and it feels like they're right
there and so yeah it just has to get
more lightweight it has to resolution
what was that like meeting Mark
Zuckerberg it was extremely
nerve-wracking like we had like a
pre-call which helped so I feel like I
was more nervous about that pre-call
um but it was it was really cool I mean
I know it's kind of cliched to say this
but it's like when you're talking to
someone you're like oh they're just a
human like me right but it's like all
the memes about him being a robot and an
alien you know like it gets in your head
but he's freaking he's actually normal
oh really he's very normal you know I
mean should I say normal because he's
not normal how is he weird then or not
weird just yeah sorry I should say I
mean you know if you it was a very
isolated you know we had the pre-call
and then the moment we got on that Zoom
the interview started because I only had
25 minutes so it was
I had you know my list of questions
um but I think the probably the most
like
like
part where I was so nervous was like
towards the end
he said something where I was like I
need a follow-up to that question
because that doesn't seem you know it
was my it was my op it was my time to
actually be like ask a smart question
because we started talking about
creators he was talking about
monetization and I feel like one thing
Facebook and Instagram do really bad is
they just take all the money they put
ads in your stories they put ads
everywhere but they don't share with
creators the way YouTube does and so he
mentioned you know in the VR World we're
doing these things like ticket in
advance and blah blah blah but that is
still
the creator has to bring the audience
and then Facebook is taking that cut
what about all the ads that are going to
be in our meta verse aren't you gonna
like do a profit share so
um I think I I didn't really get so I
got that question and at the very end
um which I wanted to actually hear so it
was cool to be able to ask the man
actually in charge of that stuff an
actual question you have
um but but yeah interviews like that are
just
you're nervous in the beginning and then
you start talking and it's like what do
you say well he he skirted the question
which was a little disappointing
um and he didn't say he just went back
to the model of creators consult merch
creators can hold events they can do all
these things
and that was just a little disappointing
to hear because again that is creators
bringing Their audience and then
Facebook taking a cut it's like you guys
got to do the work that YouTube you know
has and if you want creators to stay on
your platform and all the drama that's
happening with Instagram right now you
have to make it a platform where people
cannot just like earn a living but also
feel like they have a shot at getting
views and likes and engagement so yeah
how did you even get an interview with
Mark Zuckerberg yeah
oh man
I think so I had a podcast that creative
life that lasted for about like 125
episodes so I had a lot of like
Serendipity going for me and I'm sure
you guys have seen it with iced coffee
hour when you start interviewing people
you know you're having like deep
conversations with people you're
building a ton of relationships and I'm
sure that then puts in people's heads
that you know are doing cool things like
oh I should hit up green for that I
should hit up Jack for that and so
um that was just like a Serendipity
thing previously for my podcast I had
interviewed
um like a Facebook executive about the
Ray-Ban stories and so I got linked with
um you know people at Facebook one of
the people who worked with this guy Boz
who's now the CTO
um previously worked at full screen
where I used to be a part of full screen
and my manager used to work there and so
it was one of those things where just
like you know like oh hey I haven't seen
you in a while and you like kind of like
strike up you know just like a casual
relationship and then when an
opportunity comes up where like hey Mark
is doing a couple interviews with Sarah
B down
um they hit us up and I was one of only
like 300 views I think it was like me
garyvee and um another podcast that he
did so so yeah it was it was impressive
pretty pretty cool so I've interviewed a
lot of great people
um but the podcast just became a little
too much book and guess and I'm sure you
guys like know the stress of running a
podcast but I do miss it talking to
people so this is my new thing that I
want to do I just want to go on other
people's podcasts and talk it's a lot
easier if you just show up and uh you're
done exactly what do you think of the
new Instagram algorithm it's just
showing videos now which chances are
maybe we could clip this as a video as
an example of uh you know Instagram's
pushing videos right now and
hilarious I mean my story views got cut
into a third like overnight which is
great luckily most of my business is
like YouTube and then Twitter too
um I just did a Kickstarter where I only
posted to Twitter it was only Twitter
and Instagram and we raised like 150 000
before I even post my YouTube video
which is crazy
um but Instagram I don't have a super
big connection with just because I I
feel like I saw it coming because
Facebook did the thing where they ruined
your organic reach Facebook bought
Instagram where do you think Instagram's
gonna go so I totally understand
people's frustration and I wish it could
be different
um luckily
I'm I don't know I'll sit there and
watch reels forever it's tick tock
content it's funny I you know I get
sucked into like oh that'd be a fun
sound to use so you know I think I if I
needed to I could make a pivot into
reals but
um yeah I could definitely understand
how it's fudging over photographers and
I totally get their frustration but I
heard the new thing that all you have to
do now is turn the picture into a video
yeah people are posting their I see
[ __ ] Mosey doing this all the time he
tweets something screenshots the tweet
and then post it as a real oh a real
does that work I will say I think the
more important issue is monetization
what we were talking about earlier the
problem with Tick Tock the problem with
Instagram is everything is being
condensed into this short form crap
sometimes I'm sorry
and then there is no payoff I know
YouTube shorts channels that pull in
hundreds of millions of views per month
but they can only sell two T-shirts you
know I know tick-tockers like that at
the end of the day people are just like
giving
these platforms free engagement they're
giving these platforms all of their time
but they're not getting anything in
return which is concerning tell us about
this Kickstarter you did okay race yes
so we're day three so lab 22 it's a
premium desk accessory brand and it all
started with I'm obsessed with my iPad
right but you can oh gosh I just clicked
on one of my videos
um but a lot of people start using iPads
as like second screens to computers and
they just leave iPads up and use them as
a computer but I'm like guys it's an
iPad use it as an iPad so the iPad stand
is great because it's super flexible you
can bring it down to note taking
position and it's just really solid it's
like a chunk of metal
um and so it's just super sturdy you
know a lot of people just have plastic
junk from Amazon
um and then we also have a phone stand a
headphone stand and so we just launched
on Kickstarter three days ago and last
time I checked it was around 220 000 um
that we raised so it's been like a
whirlwind
um it has been like
when all of your validation as if your
video is like 10 out of 10 or 1 out of
10 to have something outside of that to
be like oh my gosh like people do you
know still care about me or watch my
stuff but also oh I made a product that
actually people want which has been like
extremely validating but um it's been
over a year in the making uh so so yeah
so how much is that gonna cost to make
what are you gonna sell it for how much
so the stand is a really great price
right now it's about 119.
um
yeah
um phone stand is a little bit more
pricey headphone stand
um is let's see phone screen I think is
149. I should know this but there's dual
charging so it's magsafe so magsafe
compatible phones uh it basically
magnetizes it holds your phone it
charges it at the same time and then
down below you can put airpods or tree
wireless charging
um and then the headphone stands so
making stuff is very hard right now
that's why it took us over a year we
were supposed to launch in February but
as you can you know supply chain
shortages and stuff like that it's
taking a long time things have gotten so
expensive to make and so if you do want
to make something that isn't just a hunk
of plastic it it costs you know and it
cost a ton to ship it back and then the
taxes and I I think something
interesting if people don't know about
this that makes products even more
expensive if you're making them overseas
is that Trump tariff um so when that
came into play I don't know the exact
percentage but it adds almost like like
twenty twenty five dollars onto our
products because we're shipping them
from overseas
um just from that tariff alone so
there's just so many things you have to
worry about so I'm a little tired but
I'm excited because you know it got an
amazing response so it's been it's been
fun to make something in the physical
because I'm so used to just videos so
and I'm sure you guys had you know had
it with a coffee I feel like right I'm
sure that was a cool process yeah yeah
it was definitely more work than I
expected yeah it always is right I'll
tease it here we're coming out with a
what oh let's hear it you want to hear
it yeah okay we are coming out with tea
oh that is so great that is so great
what kind a little bit amazing you know
what amazing but you know what the one
comment that I got the most often on
those uh coffee videos where it come out
with the tea it's been do the pods pods
are really expensive but pods and tea
the tea is much better profit margins uh
it's cheaper to ship there's a lot of
benefits with tea didn't you buy a condo
you renovated it you flipped it what
happened with that
okay guys I gotta take a sip of water to
prepare for this
you should do a loud sip like a yeah
Alex add some like very dramatic tipping
is contagious like yawning I don't
believe it is drinking water yeah when I
saw you went to go
drink some water I wanted to I thought I
thought you're doing it no I was doing
it for the Sip the symptoms it's
contagious just like I don't think so
yeah you know what I'm thirsty now yeah
and that's what I'm saying as soon as
you see someone drink their water you
want to don't pay attention to it now
it's so funny please do that's
interesting yeah you know what you gotta
do that though you got to do that at a
restaurant and look around at a table
and see if one person picks up the drink
certainly people guarantee yeah I don't
think so yeah
so
okay
we moved from New York to Texas I'm from
Texas originally I lived in New York for
five to six years did the YouTube thing
the city life I loved it kovid brought
us back because you know it was kind of
crazy he was good bro continue with the
story go on
Jack is having issues with water today I
know I'm really having this as well I
went to go drink another time and I was
like and then I forgot yeah all right
just keep yeah
um so you know we were
you know I watch Graham staff and videos
I gotta I gotta buy something right I
thought we weren't prepared for a single
family home yet though uh because my
fiance and I we have lived in apartments
you know our entire time we've been
together for five years so I was like do
we want to mow a yard do we you know and
like we like cool stuff we like being on
top of coffee shops and restaurants we
we kind of want New York living but in
Texas so we found a really cool place
that I'm not going to name
um
that was super cool Loft Vibes concrete
floors I meet Kevin was angry at me
because I I actually took up hardwood
floors and did polished concrete because
I wanted to yeah I like it too okay
thank you people roasted me for that
because I spent 10K on that but it was
like
um 1900. that's terrible yeah
so I did that we redid the kitchen but
again this was Peak Renault time when
everyone was doing it and so finding a
contractor
all of those things it just took way
longer than we thought it was going to
but we closed on this condo February of
2021. I don't know if you guys remember
what was happening in Texas during this
time but it was the iconic winter storm
that came through oh the ice the ice
storm it wreaked havoc yes and so we
were still stuck in New York we couldn't
get a flight to Texas you know we had
just closed this condo we were moving so
we were stuck in a hotel for a week
while we were just like hearing all this
crazy stuff happening
the building flooded so we had just
closed on the condo and like half the
building flood so we were like is her
like is our condo ruined what is going
on and so luckily the water damage went
like right up to our place so
um all of the hallways like so the
hallways the actual building the drywall
had to get completely stripped this
might be a stupid question yeah wouldn't
it have been better for a unit to be
flooded because the insurance company
would then have to pay out a pretty
heavy amount right so I'll get to that
put that into the renovation I'll get to
that because things escalate from here
hallways are completely trash because
all the pipes burst and so they ripped
up all the carpet all the drywall had to
be redone it was chaos so we finally
moved into our condo we're like okay
thank goodness we weren't flooded but oh
my gosh the hallways looked terrible the
building is like kind of in shambles
there's a new problem every day like the
AC is breaking so right off the bat
we're having to like replace the water
heater we're having to replace our
fridge again zapped with all the power
outages and stuff
um
so many things instantly went wrong and
then we get slapped with a special
assessment
for the building because all because all
of the hallways and stuff got flooded
and you know the insurance wasn't
covering everything but
so let's say now we're entering a time
where I'm talking about a hypothetical
condo okay so this is just a story time
about a hypothetical condo that's not
mine because I don't know if I can get
in trouble for this but so I kind of
like ours yeah so this is where the
chaos starts people were not stoked on
the special assessment fee because guess
how much it was so there's 200 units
we're one unit 1900 square feet a two
bedroom one guess how much our fee was
minus 15 grand yes 17K okay yeah yeah so
luckily because we had Insurance it
covered like 15K of that but we didn't
know that because the insurance process
for that was so chaotic
all of a sudden
the condo starts rolling in other things
where they want to do Renovations like
they want to okay guys you know carpets
need to be replaced so why don't we just
like renovate the entire building so
things start to get super complicated
people get angry residents decide to sue
the HOA board it's getting super messy
now they're under litigation like almost
like nine months passes nothing is
getting done so you walk in the hallways
and it looks like you're in a
construction zone for that entire time
and this was like a 500 000 condo you
know in DFW it was a nice place like we
shouldn't be living in a construction
zone everyone's doing construction so
it's so noisy all the time like people's
individual units
and so the lawsuit thing happens and I'm
going to meetings it is chaos people are
screaming at each other like a guy on
the board was like I was like you effing
[ __ ] you need to sit down like it got
heated these are all 50 to 70 year olds
you know people we're like the youngest
people there it's so not our crowd it's
it's just exhausting
and so
the lawsuit basically halts all
Renovations and it was a year and a half
and just problem after problem I mean
I I would be here all day if I was
describing more issues more payments
like more special assessments and so it
got to a point you know interest rates
were about to hike and I was just like
if we want to get out of this because
I'm so stressed out my main job needs to
just be making videos not worrying about
you know drama with HOA like right now
would be the time to do it we just
renovate it it looks nice
so we just couldn't handle it we sold it
um we basically got most of our down
payment back but yeah the kitchen
renovation that's down the hole uh you
know the money I spent on that so how
much did you lose on that probably lost
yeah
um
yeah probably lost a solid 40 50k really
money though if you bought it way back
then do you think a buyer wants to go in
when the building's in shambles and buy
a renovated unit what they have to deal
with I figured that they would just
assume like oh you know it's gonna all
no no you have to disclose this stuff
too so that's that's the thing you know
we had to disclose the drama and so it
helped that people are trying to sell
their units without the special
assessment paid so luckily luckily we
were able to say it's paid for and they
started like uh giving us the designs uh
so it was helpful to show oh hey we
actually have a direction now
so it I am so burnt I don't think we're
renting a townhouse now and I love it
there's no noise upstairs you know so
I'm like I'm renting until a house just
calls our name so it's a special
assessment just like a fee that a HOA
can slap on oh at any time at any time
and that that is why I will never be a
part of an HOA ever but I thought that
they'd take your monthly payment in
order oh yeah oh yeah like the joints oh
yeah walls or whatever like and that
stuff I thought was covered and that's
what a lot of the questions of the
residents were what happens to the 800 a
month we pay where is that money 100 a
month and that's okay and here's the
thing it didn't start that way so by the
time we were leaving the HOA had been
hiked up for a third time too what was
it when you joined
um 600 the thing is hois are audited so
you have financial statements dating
back at the very beginning and so
usually if there's anything that stands
out from that it's pinpointed unless
they're siphoning money from that I will
say unusual there's more to the story
though okay so
yeah we had a management company that
was managing it
and we were under the impression that
there were Reserve funds turns out there
was not because the management the
management was mingling funds with so
the way this building was there's a ton
of shops and uh like shops and
restaurants down below it's a different
board
for the bottom than it is for the condos
that are up top the management company
managed both things and those boards are
separate and the funds should be
separate what they were doing is just
adding all the funds together
every month and so if the restaurant
across the street had issues or stuff
like that money we would be taken from
you know the condos to fix that so it
was a mess so in the span of that time
Not only was all of that being revealed
but in that span they fired them because
yeah they didn't audit and figured out
there was no Reserve money left it was
highly mismanaged
um and they fired them and then it was
almost like starting at zero and I was
like
I would have stayed because I really
love the building if I had faith in the
HOA board
but these people again are like picture
70 year old
white dude works at Lockheed Martin
making missiles Texan it was like
a replica of that for like 200 people
and so it's just very like old school
and like I was in you know like I don't
want to it's about to I don't want to
make fun of uh
it was just a certain type of person
sure and they they don't want your help
it's my my way or the highway and I was
like this is not a productive
environment this is this is I just need
out someone can come in and just live
their life because there's nice
amenities there's a rooftop pool
for people who don't care about this
stuff it's going to be a great life
it'll make for a great rental but I'm
very involved and it just ruined my life
so what about your failed businesses yes
besides a failed renovation
I know so many failures that's why I'm
so glad I had this like Kickstarter
thing and there's something actually
working because it's been 20 20 hit and
of course like many others you're like
what am I doing with my life can I make
YouTube videos for my entire life if you
are a fan of business content you kind
of get in your head like I need to be
the entrepreneur I need to like have
rental units and do all these things
and so I kind of like got in that
mindset and I was just like okay let's
start stuff and I just kind of like did
a ton of stuff
the
point of all this it it was other
people's ideas coming to me and me being
like oh that sounds cool yeah let me hop
on that and that didn't work out and
like the moment I do something that like
was my idea I was able to pull in a
really talented team I was like oh it
worked cool so this is the hack right
but so basically the first thing that I
tried to do was one of my buddies in New
York City came to me was like yo look at
the software it's super cool and it was
super cool it was content creation where
it would take a pillar piece of content
like this podcast and just automatically
break up into micro content
um which obviously is super valuable but
it was all AI it was all automatic and
the problem with that is again it was
his thing he's the coder and I was like
oh this is amazing yeah let me come on
and I can obviously be the marketing and
content and all of that brand building
but when you're not working on the
product day in day out it's just
and you don't you can't have as much say
as that person so you know it's going to
take different directions and ultimately
it was a very hard problem to solve
because it was all based on
transcription and
when you base an app that automatically
crops and adds sound effects and does
clip splitting and all the stuff on the
foundation of a transcript it gets
really messy because the moment you go
in and change one word you like break
that time stamp if that makes sense
I don't think I'm explaining it very
well but if you've heard of that service
I think it's called descript or it's
where you edit via transcript you like
edit a video by editing text yeah I saw
somebody do an ad for that it seemed
really interesting yeah so they're doing
it probably the best but I've seen that
they're running into the problem as well
because if you go in and add uh add
something
um say oh I didn't say
you know I said two words instead of one
word
and it's in a block of a sentence like
how do you assign those time stamps to
those new two words so when I say a
sentence like this when you read it
transcript you have time stamps so so is
one second two milliseconds the next
word is that but if you go in and edit
it the user does
how do you decide what this new time
stamps are it can get very complicated
but you can say okay there's two seconds
so you just split evenly but we were
just running into a lot of technical
issues video is hard with AI and we were
like on year two it still wasn't a full
product we would get people to test it
out but it wasn't sticky content
creators have such a flow that and this
is something I've learned too is if you
have to convince someone to use it it's
not a good product right and then I try
to open up a photo video rental studio
in Dallas Texas and it's actually still
going I filmed my Kickstarter video
there but I did it with a business
partner and it was so much work when you
have five different people coming in
every single day it's essentially like
you have five clients a day that you
have to be at their beck and call and I
was like I could make one YouTube video
and make one brand deal
or I could spend every day every month
for like half of that if that makes
sense and so ultimately it just made
more sense for the business partner to
take it over because he was closer to it
he understands it more and but again the
main theme was like
people who I love coming up to me they
have this awesome idea of me being like
yeah that sounds great and like oh
software people are selling software
companies for hundreds of millions of
dollars and me just kind of being
naive and almost selfish in a way of
wanting that big payout when I'm not
even worried about like hey is this
something that people need
and so that's and so I've kind of just
like given up on that dream which has
been extremely healthy for me because
obviously like you know garyvee is my
homie
love him but when you can get so sucked
into that content and that's not you it
can actually be kind of bad because I'm
not the person who wants a bajillion
employees I do very well on my own I'll
bring in Freelancers and so that's what
I've discovered and it's it's just it's
so much better now and ironically
you know I don't want to jinx it but it
just seems like it's even working better
I might end up at you know granted a
fraction of my main goal but being more
successful and now I'm like true to
myself I'm not trying to live someone
else's dream I don't want to be CEO
founder of you know everyone like wants
to put that in their bio but it's like I
don't want employees be a CEO yeah I
mean CEO of like nothing nothing yeah
yeah he's the CEO well it's like it's
yeah it lost its meaning yeah exactly in
the old days yo used to be like yeah a
big thing
yeah it's like oh yeah he's another
e-com guy so funny funny story about
that when I first started my wedding
business I didn't want people like
mainly my clients
um to be like oh he's the CEO so on my
business card instead of putting a CEO I
think I put either event Specialists or
like wedding coordinator but I like own
the company so it was like yeah but I
feel like it it made it more
professional yeah like a wedding analyst
[Laughter]
yeah so when I mean executive because I
feel like that sounds so delicious so
yeah I think and especially for people
watching this show I think the most
important thing for you is
to figure out just what do you actually
want not everyone can have a hundred
employees and run you know a big tech
company because you know we all have
this if you're a Creator you at any
point you're like oh my YouTube channel
can just die right you always have that
in the back of your brain so the thought
is I have to build something sustainable
that's out of me so I can just go retire
on a beach and you know not have to
worry about YouTube that's like
everyone's dream right but like that's
not the most practical thing right and
so you start focusing your energy on
this big payout that
is so you just have to be so in it and
if you don't know how to code if you
don't know you know it's just it's a
much harder thing than people
um think so what type of successful do
you want to be yeah I think yeah that's
the question I've been asking I just
want to make videos and that's and
that's what I came back to it took me
four years of this journey of like what
is the next step
and now I'm like I want to make videos I
want to make I don't want to feel like I
have I am stuck to reviews right so
they'll be about tech but I like filming
and editing so I want to be creative I
just want to make stuff I don't want
full-time employees that's my biggest
Revelation from all of this
um and I want to make stuff so you know
if people are digging like you know cool
new tech stands I need it my life they
need it in theirs and that's cool so if
there's opportunities like that that
come about
um that I can create that's what I'm
gonna do and if it's not a crazy 100
million dollar payoff that's okay I
think that's what I realize too I don't
need a ton of that sounds great I don't
need that much crazy no no no I'm just
saying this for one city of it yeah
normally people come on and they're like
Grandma with you we need to you need to
figure out you need to do this you need
to do this right Instagram this does not
sound like yes yeah are you kidding me
no when I started cutting everything
remember that Jack yeah about a month
ago I went through and I cut probably 80
percent of what I was doing and now all
I focus on the main Channel this second
Channel that's it and that's changed
your perspective yeah with all of this
no 100 million dollar payout no no
because I realized to get that 100
million dollar payout you have to put
that same attention and focus and
passion as I'm I'm putting in my videos
in a new business I'm not interested in
that I have no desire to have employees
build a big business put my time in that
hell yeah Graham yeah yes no I really I
hate the responsibility I realize I do
best when it's just me I'm responsible
for myself
um obviously I mean having a great team
so between like Alex and Jack I I could
I would go crazy with the third person I
know exactly and is management I have my
lawyers I have
um you know I have Freelancers that I
use but it's very a lot of my
frustration is someone not delivering
and then I stew I write notes and I'm
like okay I'm gonna tell them that they
did this wrong but then I never share it
because I feel bad so I am so bad at
management managing people and I'm like
well you don't have to do that so I'm
now making less and ironically My Views
are better because I'm making less
videos I'm spending more time on the
title and thumbnail and the concept and
making them good and they're doing
better that's something that that you
know we went on Mr Beast and that's
something that I learned from him is
that he's so focused on just making the
best video for the for the main Channel
and that's it but everything else from
his side but he has hundreds of
employees and you know but he's found
other people that he really tries to
delegate but his focus is just main
Channel and the way he works is like if
he doesn't make the best videos
everything else fails so he just needs
to make the best videos everything else
will fall into place yeah and for me
it's like I want to keep making the
videos because that's where I'm the
happiest I'm taking anything off of that
it's just like at least for now and I
have no desire and I will say
people underestimate how much time it
takes to just make a YouTube video and
so with all of these different side
projects that I was doing I was I was
like I literally do not have the time
for this so I think people think oh if I
can make a you know if I can be a
successful YouTuber then I will take
that and then make a company from it but
it's like if you're not really good at
operations and delegating you're just
not gonna have the time and so that's
why I've refocused on like everything
has to be it has to do 100 with my
YouTube channel and that's how I think
ultimately things you know will be
successful and I don't it's been really
tough Alex has dealt with me in terms of
delegating Alex knows how difficult are
you still editing the main channel of
the videos I am yeah good good job yeah
so I have two questions here
um I so I'm a huge fan of your content
and I remember when I was making the
Vlogs you commented on one of the Vlogs
so as somebody who's at least watched
one of the vlogs
yeah what did you think yeah what did
you think about them and um tell Graham
that he's hated for cutting them
[Music]
because I watched a lot of your stuff I
ironically I watched this to family and
iced coffee hour but I think what a lot
of people have said is like they find
you through main Channel videos but once
you're versed on finance you're like
you're good so you move to the other
stuff
and I love the Vlogs because I felt like
I was getting to know you guys more
um but I will say you guys were saying
oh this is an opportunity to reach
beyond your audience when I saw it more
of a play to go deeper with your already
existing audience so I feel like if
those expectations are maybe you know
aligned a little bit more maybe it would
be more sustainable and fun but because
I can understand how if you want to
reach beyond your audience the Vlogs
probably aren't going to be the way to
do it because like I I was like watching
every single one because I was like oh
this makes you have two let's check up
too did you like them more in the
beginning or near the end so the end was
when I was posting three times a week
iPhone yeah
I think I wash all of them
um you need a preference I'm trying to
give me some subjects that because I've
posted once a week with Alex editing
through the high edits and then we went
three times a week with me just filming
what was yeah what was the like because
I remember the iPhone you would like sit
on the couch and just talk about and
post new video and stuff like that and
that was cool I liked both like I like
the mix well I found that the iPhone did
significantly better subscribers were up
we're losing subscribers posting once a
week and she's like this is unacceptable
and I'm spending my time doing this yeah
and I'm worried about title thumbnail
and it's taking so then I just went
iPhone I stopped caring it did so well
funny enough I did my aquarium tour
started off as a 10 out of 10 by far and
that aquarium Tour by the way was just a
last minute Macy was like it was like
one take yeah it was all one take yeah
Macy's coming home in 20 minutes I'm
like I have some time let me share the
aquarium one take post it up and it's a
[ __ ] like it bombs now it's a two it's
one of them it's almost the best
performing video okay is something I'm
noticing with YouTube and this is why I
don't get so depressed when I instantly
hit like an 8 out of 10 or something is
if you actually make a good video it now
has a long tail so I'm noticing I do
Studio tours and stuff and so I did a
studio tour of Austin Evans Place it
didn't do that great but I was confident
in the thumbnail and title so I just
didn't change it I was like if this is
going to do well it'll do well it took a
month but now it's like you know 120 1
30.
um and I've been noticing like the past
I would say
three to six months YouTube is taking
more time to find an audience for your
video sometimes you know you'll have a
flop but
um I feel like that has been super
encouraging for me because it really
does feel like something's different I
have a question for you I actually have
and this is something I've been
wondering why do you go the route of
like percentages instead of like hiring
uh people as like a salary or maybe like
a retainer it seems like you say oh if
you do this you get a certain percentage
correct that's just Jack okay okay okay
that was in the very beginning the
podcast made nothing like Jack was I
knew Jack was going to be at a loss for
quite some time with no guarantee of
ever making anything back and in the
beginning I'm like yeah sure let's do
that never thought anything of it and uh
yeah I think we were like maybe eight to
ten episodes and I was kind of getting
tired of it but I didn't want to like
Jack down yeah because yeah it's good
incentive he's putting so much work
until I'm like yeah I'm like not feeling
it I don't feel like filming this so I
kept doing it I'm really glad but uh
yeah so yeah it would have been would
have been uh you know more advantageous
for me Financial probably just to give a
salary but you know what uh Jack really
put in so much yeah yeah and really it
wouldn't be the same with without yeah
the way that makes sense because it then
gets gets stoked right because you feel
you're a part of it yeah
I mean here's the thing I don't like to
see myself as someone that's like purely
financially motivated because I know
there are plenty of other cash grabs
around me I could easily be capitalizing
on but at the same point it's like
having a pretty strong financial
incentive for the podcast to do well
definitely made me work a lot harder
like you know to the point of exhaustion
and then passed and then some like
especially when we're really in that
growth we have ownership right six to
six months to like year yeah definitely
speaking of money yeah uh how much money
are you making yeah
okay if you if you don't if you don't
mind when I first reached out to Grandma
I was like I yeah I
am
um the past few years when everyone was
making so much money in 2020 2021 I was
just like freaking out because we were
we were in the middle of Manhattan and
of course the world was going crazy
um I had some just weird I all of a
sudden got awful awful migraines and I'm
still trying to figure out but just some
weird Health stuff happened and then
we're moving to Texas and so so much
life happened that on 2019 I was like on
this trajectory of like you know I was
doing good I would say from 2016 to
2019 you know I started with maybe in
2016 I was making 100K including that
adobe salary plus you know AdSense
I can't share that okay yeah um but it's
a lovable everything else
it's a livable salary
um
and then each year I was just building
building luckily because I was doing
video work with an agency before
um brand deals came really naturally for
me so all of a sudden when I was like oh
I can put my spin on a you know branded
video that's exciting because I was so
used to making videos only for Brands so
uh naturally I just started doing brand
deals and
you know I'm brand friendly so it just
worked out and I would say from there
like I was kind of compounding probably
like doubling every year 2019 was my
best year ever where if if you take out
um lawyer fees management fees I
probably grossed around 800k wow but
that was me going ham I was at
conferences every month I was giving
talks I was doing like six to seven
videos a month almost all of them were
branded
um well those numbers probably aren't
perfect but
um
and you know I was like doing stuff and
so 2019 was really really good and like
I just got engaged
um start of 2020 everything's looking up
and then 2020 happened and I had a rough
time with 2020. so I've kind of been
like building back the blocks
um
besides the money was it just well it
was well moving it was New York first of
all we were so freaked out you know
because covid first hit Manhattan New
York and so dealing with that was crazy
um other things that I don't super want
to mention but just life stuff life
stuff and then moving to Texas in the
condo
was insane like I don't know if I can
emphasize how much that stressed me out
and I think it it kind of proved me that
I don't know if I ever actually want to
own a house
um I know I'm telling Graham Stefan that
but yeah it's like I get so stressed out
by little things so when something
breaks her townhouse I just like text
the person and it's amazing and I love
that and so the condo too
um there was noise every day it just
made making things so difficult
um so I've been slowly building back up
and again I was trying all those
businesses my focus was super split and
so my income went back to like early
days basically and now now I'm like
building back up
um but now I'm more focused on long-term
projects I don't need in the beginning I
was like how do you get back to 2019
Sarah hire these people hire the
full-time people and scale and do all
this and when I hated my life doing that
I was like I don't need 800k a year what
do you actually need I need money for
doordash I need money to fly first class
because I you know I'm a homebody I hang
out with my cat and like to be
comfortable I hate flying and that's
about it so I'm like if you make
a few you know a few six figures a year
your life is going to be exactly how you
like to live it and so I think I've kind
of just let go of
you know needing to one up and I've
found my place in a much more peaceful
peaceful place I have hit a million net
worth so many times and gone under it
just because condo and a lawsuit and
um so many things so yeah I've
that's been fun but but yeah so I would
say I I'm floating around that area as
a general net worth but I've never
shared that so there you go Sarah peachy
exclusive the ice coffee are I just had
a question I was gonna ask I completely
forgot it you got so drowned in the
numbers man they were so good so yeah
yeah podcasting because people are all
always like numbers numbers and
what was the first time you flew first
class I remember it so clearly Graham so
when I was doing the Adobe stuff I was
basically like kind of like an adobe
Ambassador so I was going to conferences
probably three times a month which is
like very intense and you know they I
could never choose so I'd be in the back
of the plane I'd be middle C that was
like the start of like I need to make
money because I'm like I will never do
this again for some reason I don't know
why it gets so under my skin like being
middle seat of airplane having people's
arms shove off your arm and you're just
feeling powerless but
um
it's like you know villain origin
stories right there but um being
sarcastic so right after that you know I
remember having a little bit of YouTube
money and signing up for
uh my first fancy credit card so uh I
got the Delta what is it called I still
have it today
um Sky miles it's yeah yeah it's the
Delta Amex Sky miles
and I started building up points and uh
you know I bought an upgrade with Miles
and I was probably like 2017 and I was
going to a conference and a company
basically paid now I have more leverage
if a company ever wants me to travel
anywhere I don't do it unless it's first
class because I just stay home you know
like covid taught us you can do
everything at home
um but yeah back in the day you know a
company wouldn't do that and I upgraded
uh with the help of that card and I was
like yes I think I think it was a trip
to New York when I wasn't living there
yet so I think that was I think that was
actually 2016 so I might have been it
was the end of my residency but um but
yeah and I've never gone back yeah you
can I fly first I have a quick I did I
flew first class so um I went last
minute to surprise Macy and her family
at Disneyland in Florida and the first
class option was like not that much more
yeah and so I just did it uh because I
figured one of the may as well
experience this it's incredible I got so
much work done yeah and that's and
that's the thing too that I I do in my
head I'm like the ROI of having a
guaranteed plug of having space is I do
my best email work on a plane so it's
actually extremely productive too on the
way here I organized my entire desktop
of my computer I have no more
screenshots on my desktop it was so
productive
but they stack on top of it yeah yeah so
that's my that's my one splurge and then
if you want more numbers I looked at how
much I spent on doordash last year so
um bless my accountant he lays all of
this out for me so last year I spent uh
I think it was 14 000 from doordash and
that is not that's just doordash That's
not including when I go out to eat but I
don't mail your door dashing almost
sounds do you have a monster per day do
I have a pantry actually no I don't I
don't have a pantry my townhouse we use
like we had to get a cabinet forty
dollars a day on doordash yeah yeah so
my here's the thing I don't like to be
uncomfortable and I don't like to cook
and so I'll tell you my first moment of
success in New York was I just moved
there and making you know enough cash
where I started eating at sweetgreen 13
salads every single day for lunch and
because when I moved into my gross New
York apartment I cooked the sad chicken
and it was somehow pink and rubbery and
I was just like I can't do this I can't
do this anymore and so
really it's so it's downhill from here
when I when I could pay for salads that
sweet green I was like this is all I
need so that yeah so food and even I
need to show you guys this clip uh of
you guys talking about first class I
don't know if you guys seen it but it's
Steve Harvey okay check this out
pay a little extra money to fly first
class what it does is it conditions your
mind once you get in first class and you
see how wide the seats are everybody get
a washcloth they got a menu you get to
decide what you want all the drinks is
free once you sit in first class one
time
and next time you get on a plane it's
very difficult
to walk past them seats and then your
mind starts thinking of ways to get back
to First Class you're talking about like
making money
I actually relate yeah I feel like a lot
of people are just thinking of going to
debt you know they're gonna find a way
okay that actually spoke to me though
on ironically because that was my
motivation like in the like and I
remember okay I remember the first time
too that I sat sat in the like 1A and I
was like 1A I was like just saying that
on my ticket I was like one a I'm gonna
live the 1A life you know
um so that was cheesy but I understand
where he's coming from because that
actually was
a flip that that switched him in my
brain a switch that flipped in my brain
um
and now yeah and it also I'm like good
now I'm like when I finally looked
around and I was like the life I'm
living right now I am good with you know
it changes how you do anything I flow
not first class after that every flight
after that has been not first class like
we went to North Carolina yeah when we
it was fine Dave Ramsey podcast yeah are
you flying first class no oh we're going
together yeah oh cool yeah if you're if
you're not in the middle seat if you're
not in the middle seat it's manageable
but yeah that's the ones it's nice but I
feel like if I were alone I would do it
because then I feel like I just tone
down work but wait can I say one more
thing about the Steve Harvey clip yeah
because I I will say too
um early in my career as well when
you're like the only young chick when
you're walking in with your like sweats
and you know beanie and you just like
don't care but you like look around and
you're with a bunch of like business
Bros and like you're the only like human
that looks like you I will say it is
pretty motivating because like I feel
like for me there was power in that
because I'm like yeah I'm important like
you major in this yeah in the seat you
know and so that's the kind of energy
that I guess what's that like being one
of the few females because I feel like
Tech YouTube is very male dominated it
seems like that at least yeah especially
Tech yeah yeah
significantly in Tech I will say that
the tech space Tech YouTube is amazing
um the people I've been able to collab
with they are so supportive they've been
supportive since the beginning
um and they I feel like they make an
effort the larger World
um
yeah it can be there can be challenges
but I think my entire life I've kind of
been used to like I played electric
guitar I was in a band so you know I was
the like 13 year old girl playing
electric guitars and being into pedals
and amps and stuff so I've understood
kind of this like demographic that you
have to play in when your interests kind
of skew more techy if that makes sense
so I've had a lot of practice but there
are things that come up like you know
collabs that didn't happen because the
girlfriend of the person you're supposed
to collab with didn't want that to
happen because he's not allowed to hang
out with like another girl so
um yeah like that's that's literally
what happened
so that like rocked me because it was
right after the Casey thing
and I was going to all these conferences
and stuff and it was the first big
creator that like recognized me for my
work before you know everyone's like oh
you're the Casey girl and this person
was like oh my God like that series that
you did and this thing that you did and
they were you know he was like
recognizing work outside of
um that Casey video and he was a big
Creator so this club was like I was
putting up I was like this is a really
big collab this is gonna be good for me
and we
we literally filmed it
and he didn't post it because of his
girlfriend didn't want it out there and
you have to understand I like
I don't look like I'm gonna go steal
your guy you know like women are more
than just like vessels of like you know
uh I get it you know yeah
so it's like that was like extremely
disappointing it was the most like I was
like in I'm not gonna say where I am
because then you can start tracing
things back but I mean I I like call my
mom I was like bawling my eyes out
um because like business things don't
happen sometimes because of that like
that can get in the way and so I guess a
practical point for men
would just be like make it not weird and
it won't be weird that that situation
wasn't weird but for some reason his
girlfriend felt uncomfortable yeah and
so a lot of times you know that
responsibility uh is on the woman
unfortunately like don't wear
promiscuous clothes don't do this don't
do that right but then there's also
professionalism so anyways there's just
there's a lot if he was a girlfriend or
did he tell you that specifically
because I feel like if my girlfriend
would act like that I would not want it
because oh it was a girlfriend's psycho
oh he was he was throwing her under the
bus you guys are gonna throw it together
if you're gonna freak out when I tell
you who this is are they still together
yeah are they still together yes yeah no
but but here's the thing wait let me
guess what can I guess no no let's not
guess what if he was talking you up a
lot to the girlfriend before yeah
because then again and again I don't
know what's going on in their life and
I'm thinking maybe and maybe there's a
small chance that behind the scenes he's
really talking you up the fact that he's
been watching you for quite some time
maybe there's like something there my
girlfriend that's right but guess what
devil's advocate here men are allowed to
like women's content I remember one of
the most attractive things about my
fiance John was like he was like oh my
favorite YouTuber is Lilly Singh and he
like it's gonna sound crazy but he had
intra like he wasn't you know a super
bro and you know he would like things
like you're allowed to like women's
content it doesn't mean that you're
sexually attracted to them you know okay
I'm gonna write this down oh
[Laughter]
that's yeah
jeez yeah and what and so I've had and
this is someone who is so loved by the
community and I just have this like
weird like damn you like
just you like I yeah I guess you know I
don't know the situation I have a there
has to be more then that we're just not
aware of because to me that seems like
from from that person he shouldn't have
like he shouldn't have explained it in
depth in paragraphs like he was
literally like I was here for her on
this uh trip so it doesn't look good
that he was like with another girl
recording a video and yeah so that's so
odd uh you know but I see the thing for
me is it's it's so far-fetched that I
want to rationalize and be like well
it's because of this oh and this is why
I would never publicly say it because
like we can get a lot of views
I would instantly become the enemy
because I mean you understand who that
is yeah I mean I have so many
you know wow that is really surprising
yeah well okay anyway yeah yeah so but
overall you know things like that can
happen and then you just take
whatever
um but overall the actual Tech YouTube
space is amazing I mean the the people
I've had opportunities to collaborate
like iJustine Austin Evans Marquez
um everyone is so cool in this space um
so I yeah I feel super thankful that I
landed in Tech YouTube and not in like
commentary YouTube or mainstream YouTube
because you know I've had interactions
with some of those people and it's it's
very different so Finance YouTube's
super nice
what are some of the things you've
learned from some of those other people
like Katie Marquez oh my God yeah
amazing yeah he's he's is he the top or
um I would say Mark has a Linus Linus is
awesome I'm going through some drama
with him right now but it's like it's
like we it's
yeah so lab 22 is the desk accessory
brand I just launched we've been working
on it for over a year
there is so much leading up to this I
talked about it for the first time like
two months ago but it was just an email
list so it wasn't a lot of announcements
so we've been leading up to this
he floated a name of his new big project
his his uh testing facility where
they're going to review Tech really
technically and it's really it's gonna
be awesome
but they were like okay guys we finally
got
um some names that were gonna float and
this was Friday and he was like what do
you guys think about lab 32
and literally that's when I was starting
to like get ready for the launch and all
this stuff and you know we launched
Monday only two days after that lab 22.
and so like half of my comments
everywhere are like Sarah what about
line you know lab 32 and it's like it's
become this thing on Twitter
um
and it's the name we almost have like
the same exact name of like new brands
that we've been launching so it's not
but we're friends and we've collabed and
so we've been going back and forth very
cordially
um so that's some recent fun stuff so
we'll have to figure that out but you
know that your thing was lab there's no
way I mean it was we I shouted out the
email list so I said it maybe twice
before I definitely uh first but there's
no there's no way that he could have
known
um so it was it was really just
extremely bad luck
um and so I could tell that they were
like you know like oh how committed are
you to this and I'm like have you seen
the kicks Twitter have you seen the
beautiful website
um and it's funny because like there's
some brand overlap and stuff but we'll
figure it out what did you come up with
the name lab 22. yeah lab 22 yeah so
we started with that creative life which
is the name of my podcast but legally
um and I was like hot off of a lawsuit
about names and stuff so I was like I
don't want any issues with the name so
that creative life wasn't going to work
out and then we were like desk
accessories you know like when I'm
editing late at night I'm like in the
lab right and then I was like we're
launching in 2022 22 has always been my
number so I played basketball in high
school I was a big basketball player so
you know I have all these jerseys of
with the number 22 so I was like oh lab
22.
um trick out your lab and 22 so that's
why it's not super complex but
um and how did you get 32. it um gosh I
forgot what he said on the podcast but
uh
I think off of some like retro computer
system or something and it does make
sense for their brand like they're
building a Tech Lab where they can test
things out so I totally understand why
it's like Tech 32. uh because it really
is like a lab you know but I think a lot
of people are like oh LTT Labs you know
or something like MIT Labs yeah
LTT Labs because other channels LTT so
it sounds just like coincidence it was a
coin yeah yeah we came in hot with the
other drama this is actually
I'm friends with him so it's it's not
like real drama it's everyone on Twitter
that's making a drama so oh yeah people
are just confused so I think he's going
to mention in his podcast Friday so it
shouldn't
I'm such a big fan of this pod I
literally send them notes of things that
we could talk about because I'm like I
never get to talk about Finance stuff on
my channel yeah this is amazing
hopefully hopefully it was a good pod
for everyone yeah but yeah yeah what
questions you have for us yeah I mean I
would love to hear more about your
journey to this like oh let's actually
let's focus let's get back to the basics
right
um did that affect how you're gonna make
YouTube videos like are you gonna make a
different style for your main Channel or
how does that manifest into the main
Channel I'm just less stressed out okay
no um there were a few things that just
stressed out I'm just thinking I I
remember I was like I had to plan a
video and you know I had to sign some P
it's something stupid I just had like
sign some papers and you know I really
got down to it was like I I don't like
doing that and everyone that we have in
the park almost everyone is telling me
Graham you should do this and you should
do that and if you hire this and you
grew this business over here you'd make
so much more money and at the end of the
day I was like I was just pulling my
attention away and it made me realize
that like I am not like I don't consider
myself like a business owner I don't
have a desire to run a business I don't
have a desire to have a whole bunch of
employees
um and I'm just like where I'm really
the happiest is like sitting on the
couch making a video without anything
else to think about creating things yeah
and so when I really put into
perspective it's like okay I could do
these other things it's really gonna is
it really worth my time to do these
things compared to what I could just be
doing without that stress and so I
started cutting like one thing after
another it started with the Vlog and
that was just you know that wasn't a
business but it was just cutting down
then uh you know Millennial money was
just something for us I just I wanted
that time back and I just you know I I
just wanted to to have something where
didn't have to think about it just one
less thing that's just on my shoulders
and it felt so good
uh in terms of like everything that I
just felt like a weight was lifted so I
kept doing it and uh pretty soon you
know I sold off one rental property
loved it that was great I'm selling off
another one these are these are the the
first ones I bought so it's not nothing
big but I just lost this energy yes yes
and it's it's like sure you know the 80
20 principle that's what I kept going
back to I'm like
20 of the work I'm doing over here is
resulting in 80 of My outcome so why not
I just focus on that and everything else
is just noise that's why I stopped my
podcast one day it might come back but
now I've made peace where I see it as a
body of work I've interviewed like 125
legendary people
let that be what it is you know and so I
I feel you so on the other side what
would be your ideal like for the Graham
Stefan Enterprises if you could do
whatever you want with his business what
would it be because I feel like you're
on the opposite side oh it's just like
just allowing Jack be like hey if I
could like if you could run yeah if you
could run all of his stuff what would
that look like well it's hard because I
don't know what exactly his like day to
day looks like but if I'm taking it from
what he's told me is to space basically
like planning and like filming and
reviewing and stuff like that I would
just say figure out where most of the
time is going see if you can find
someone to potentially trim the fat on
that and somehow like make it faster and
more efficient uh and then make that
happen because I know for Graham right
now and this is something I brought up
but like it's very hard for him to take
time off at least like extended periods
of time like three four days you know
what I mean like he can do like one day
here and there but I would like if
something were to happen some crazy
opportunity he can go take Advan image
of it and go somewhere for three four
days or someone can potentially present
him with like three you know let's say
one script with three different
variations of different parts and then
he can say oh I like this or maybe it's
80 done and he could just do like the 20
on the top of that or something like
that I will say that yeah the script
thing is hard because I I try to get
help with script and I'm like that's not
me this is me is is that so I understand
that but then yeah you want to feel like
you can be able to
go somewhere and I I attribute my entire
career to Serendipity in the beginning I
just said yes to everything and it's
still paying dividends and so I think
having a healthy healthy balance of both
of those worlds is good yeah I really
love working now I mean those things so
it's like for me traveling anywhere is
usually just an inconvenience and it's
like I will say I just wanted to say
Santa Barbara and it's it would be such
a quick trip for umac I went there with
John my fiance and it was amazing
beaches in Santa Barbara are gorgeous it
was the first time I disconnected in
maybe two years and so I feel like
you're so close to just so many pretty
beaches and in places you could you know
you could probably start bopping over to
but yeah but you got to do it now but I
have a little bit more free time now
that I've cut a lot of the other stuff
it's just less to think about and then
also when you are
because I had to stop feeling stressed
about not taking a break and so once you
can free your mind of like I like
working so I'm going to continue to work
until maybe I should take a break and so
now that I've taken the stress off of
the pressure of like you should take a
break and all that stuff it's much
better yeah but what would you say you
would just Tire a scripter really I
would look into it that's the thing it's
like you really haven't looked into it
that much so you could say it's not
possible but we really don't know but
then here's the thing I mean like I
thought all of the the other things
Graham was doing on the side that was a
lot and he was definitely seemed like he
was really stressed out and losing focus
on the stuff that really mattered but
now since he has dropped all of those
things and it does seem like he's at a
place where his workload's very
manageable I think that's totally fine
and if he really does like enjoy
scripting and stuff like that I see no
problem with it I don't know if there's
really much I would change now yeah the
hardest part for me is topics scripting
if if I had a topic that was presented
to me every morning like do this and it
will do well I could do that so well but
it's figuring out the topics and the
angle that will make it do well
so and that's YouTube and that's what
makes it so hard I have so many ideas
but I don't have so many thumbnails and
titles so so much gets left on The
Cutting Room floor so yeah Jeremy's
actually been helping me with uh some
video topics he'll throw me the topics
that he thinks would make a good video
that he wouldn't cover maybe it's just
not his stock market audience so the
China video he started sending me these
videos hey
um this is a really interesting video
check this out it's like doing a lot of
research but if it wasn't for Jeremy
sending me that at like 11 p.m at night
on like a weekday and I'm like looking
look at it I'm like Macy look at this
video and I'm showing her this like this
incredible thing who are you doing your
Twitter uh no okay because that is
something I've noticed because I am so
on Twitter and I'm like Grandma Stefan
up his Twitter and it's working so uh
speaking of that uh that is the only
person who I think I would ever trust
with the script and he's helped me with
research
um I got to do a huge chat I just have
to shout him out it's a market it's
called the market sentiment blog I'll
link to them down below in the
description just seriously just it's
free it costs you nothing just don't and
check it out he's a Blog that I
referenced in a video like a year ago
and I referenced him as this person who
compiled This research I'm like it's so
good that I mentioned it in a video and
then I linked to him in the description
and he I think I emailed him or he
emailed emailed me I was like dude thank
you so much for that that shout out we
just gained 5 000 new subscribers to our
page it like doubled this is incredible
I was like yeah no his his blog is so
good and he posts once a week and so I
kept just like shouting out his blog
because he had so much good research and
I'd just go there and then reference
what he found and say hey guys just
check this out down below in the
description uh and we kept talking and
then he made me the pitch and says
Graham you have scripts for your videos
you create a newsletter and I'll do it
for you
um and so yeah and from that he's been
perfect like he'll take my script but
then take it a step further and then
create his own graphs for like the
research that I found that's so good uh
and then we've gone back and forth and
then he took over the Twitter but uh
yeah the Twitter's is so good We Grew
From I think it was 50 000 to 130 000.
wow um Twitter followers in like three
months four months something like that
and uh you know I'm so happy to give him
like any promotion whatsoever
um just because this information is good
but he's someone I would trust and
that's good help me with research like
he's even come to me Instagram if you
want to do a video on this topic like
I'll help you research on it and I think
that's fantastic yeah and I think that's
the best way to find people for for us
is like people who naturally integrate
and don't just say hey what can I do
yeah but it's like hey I will do this
this and this and you only have to say
yes and and because I know you are
adamant about emailing Graham in the
beginning that was a funny story but
like I think that's so helpful for
people if you admire someone or or
there's an entrepreneur or a YouTuber
that you want to work with don't email
them and just say hey I'll do anything
say hey I noticed your podcast doesn't
have Clips on Tick Tock here's some
examples that you can post right now
free of charge if you want uh to put me
on a monthly retainer to have you know
these clips every single month hit me up
it's this price if you make it so easy
for them to say yes like a lot of stuff
can happen
um that way market sentiment blog I'll
link to it down below in the description
that's awesome yeah one more question
yeah if you have time
I feel like
uh Finance YouTube overall is going
through an interesting thing because I
was I went so Ham on it during covid
right because oh my God it's so crazy
and you know you have all everything but
now it seems like okay inflation markets
down what is new right are you feeling
that fatigue on your side just like
personally okay yeah yeah if you're
feeling it I'm feeling it yeah ten times
worse yeah because I'm like how do you
like mentally like wake up and be like
how am I gonna talk about this the good
news is that if I set a goal and I say
no matter what and the day doesn't end
until I finish a video I'll finish the
video okay it's never been an issue of
that uh the hard because because the
thing is I know 100 I could always
there's always like 30 topics that I
could revert back to there's truly
nothing through Evergreen videos so it's
like I can make another video on passive
income credit card yeah and the thing is
like those do well because nobody goes
back and watches the videos that I've
posted like three years ago uh so unless
you get that recommended you're never
seeing it and most new subscribers will
never see those videos so they're
missing out on that so every now and
then I do try usually once a year I try
to go back through videos that I think
are important remake them better and
make them updated so let's say it's like
the top five ETFs that you could buy
um of 2019 well you know even though it
might be pretty similar today we could
improve the video make it funny or make
it more interesting and bring it up
today and the funny thing is too uh
people think that the videos that I've
done in like 2018 are no longer valid to
be like oh dividends that's 2018 markets
changed it's almost like you have to
make a new video on that for people to
think it's a good point so yeah so
there's always like probably 20 topics
realistically that I could make if
there's truly nothing and I do that so
usually like once every other week
there'll be one of those videos and then
it kind of fills the space in between
the time but yeah there's definitely not
a lot to talk about so you know I would
like to Pivot I think at some point but
uh you know I think it'll just happen
naturally yeah
do you have the podcast I mean that
keeps things new I like the flow I think
we got a good flow they trickle in
through the main Channel sometimes
they'll dabble in the second Channel a
little bit some reactions uh by the time
they make it to the podcast though and
the podcast I I really hope is growing
its own audience I have a feeling
there's a lot of over probably 80
overlap but I love the podcast to have
more uh of its own demographic that's
separate where they're like who's
totally see that yeah because you're
bringing in new people all the time and
yeah is great now don't stop the podcast
oh God honestly I would say the podcast
would would be the well I don't want to
jinx it now I feel like I'm gonna jinx
it I'm gonna jinx it I know I have the
podcast I I think has a lot of longevity
there's a lot to the podcast that I
really enjoy yeah I enjoy it yeah and
it's cool now with the podcast so
sometimes I get a little bummy if we
post an episode and it doesn't do that
well but now I feel like we have so many
different faucets for like growth uh
we've been doing Instagram reels of the
podcast I've been seeing your tick tocks
yeah oh God they take yeah it was funny
uh my dad sends me to he's like he gets
recommended the tick tocks yeah randomly
he's like I saw this Tick Tock I thought
it was really good I'm like you you're
for you're on Tick Tock and then like
you got recommended that like he's not
searching this out like he got
recommended that's amazing hey Dad
imagine this gets clipped up did you
know fun fact did you know Tick Tock
recommends based on like location yes
yeah so if you so if you're like an
aspiring filmmaker it would be wise to
like post your tick tocks when you're in
LA or something I just learned that you
get a lot of Las Vegas tick tocks yeah
but uh yeah but so we've been doing
Instagram
um Facebook we're in the process of
Snapchat good yeah I've heard people
make good money yeah it's pretty crazy
like the amount of reach that you can
get on all these other platforms but
it's also interesting to note that they
don't really like trickle down into that
that's what I was saying I was like all
of these views but what does it do
however if your face is on there it's
brand You're Building brand or it's hard
because it's like this false sense of
confidence that you get because it's
like no there is there is real value to
its value if you're if you're reaching
out for a potential guest in the podcast
you can say hey on average our videos
will get or each episode will get 30
million views of reach and you're
including all of your short form and
everything and all they care look at the
YouTube videos it's like 20 000 years no
but the thing is at the end of the day
if we're having a guest on that's of
that level where you like actually need
to pitch it to them all they really care
about is reach that's very important yes
it's superficial stock so it's like
what's your follower account what's your
view count I agree with you on that but
yeah it makes I agree yeah it makes it a
lot more attractive especially if we can
disperse it on all these different
platforms they have confidence that like
okay yeah I could have seen on all these
different platforms with all these
different populations for viewer
demographics and that's a lot more uh
interesting to them no that's a great
Point really briefly I I'm not trying to
to plug anything or anything but uh no
I'm not I'm not sponsored by Lexar yeah
okay
last podcast
um people were like I can't believe Alex
got a sponsor like I just have to point
it out guys it's kind of a joke but also
kind of music certainly not a joke no no
don't you dare act like it's a joke
no but let's be honest before before I
brought anything I did float the idea
around and um you know we agreed as long
as it wasn't anything too crazy I will
say the wedding thing shook me to my
core you're against it I was I was
shocked that was even a thought to be
honest are you serious and that was a
good idea I was like I I get it now
after listening to it I could understand
how you could get to that point but I
feel like a wedding is like such a pure
thing or that you tried to keep that way
that I was like oh my gosh I feel like
that yeah yeah
you also have you also have to remember
like when people ask my wife like oh you
got married she's like yeah we got
married in December because of tax
purposes and like like you have to
remember like who you're dealing with
you know wait what uh what are reasons
to get married in a certain month
because tax purpose doesn't matter as
long as you're married yeah yeah so
because here's the thing we were going
to get married in 2022 okay
um but it was the end of 2021 I had just
started my own business I had all this
income we're in like this tax bracket
where we're not maxing out and um so by
getting married we we got a tax break
yeah yeah Alex literally realized that
as I was just sitting at my desk I'm
like you know you can save money with
the being married and he's like what
what I have to propose and it was
probably like honestly Jack do not throw
me under the bus
it was like 30 seconds that lapsed but
no you could put it up yes it's funny
yeah but he knew he was gonna do it
anyways but it was just yeah I told Jack
I was like you know what yeah like I
knew I was gonna do it anyway but we're
probably yeah Now's the Time I'm
probably eloping because of how
expensive things are but yeah I've
engaged for almost two years now we got
engaged February 2020 right before the
pandemic in New York it's tragic times
for getting married
we now were just saying let's go back to
New York just rooftop dinner small
ceremony with just a media family
because like I I'm not yeah I'm not a
planner and so
I'm not a planner John's not a planner
and so we just haven't gotten married
because of that you know so we would
love to get married but we just need to
do something simple yeah covid
complicated that makes sense yeah Eli
Jones thank you so much for supporting
that patreon you make a difference and
you're the reason why they wake up in
the morning that's true
all right thank you so much for coming
on really appreciate it thanks for
having me on Instagram good night and
make sure to get your free stock down
below make sure to buy some Lexar stuff
thanks guys